- Is it kind of an amazing thing I know
you've probably been
asked this a million times
but to be a part of
something so monumental
like so important and
pop culture like everyone
rushed on Thursday nights
to watch that show.
Like we literally everyone
I know watched it.
Like that's incredible-
- Yes
It's funny now I mean, it felt really huge
but the way things are
now with like social media
and streaming and your ability
to binge watch something
that was back before, you
only get VCRs back then
nobody knew how to-
- You do weight
- Yeah but nobody could
figure out how to tape a show.
- I did.
(crowd laughing)
- There're few right there
you could press record
but like to program and you got the news?
you know what i mean so but now it feels
somehow just as relevant
now as it did back then.
- Yeah.
- It's it's funny 'cause
we're all so much older now
You know what I mean
and you were in the TV
they look at this so
young and then he come on-
- He think you look baby
- like Jesus!
(Everyone laughing)
- I feel like that was my career as well.
Could you leave the house though back
in that height of it all?
'cause I remember we were
actually both at the same awards.
I can't remember what it was
but it was during American Idol
and y'all were a couple
of y'all were there.
And everybody was swarming around you all.
And so I was like, Oh my
God, that's gotta be rough.
- Yeah well you know
there's some weird things
that happened back back then.
- Like what?
(crowd laughing)
- I remember one time,
so it was during the week
it was just like during the afternoon
I had to be flipping channels
I was watching the news
and for some reason, they had
like a split screen on the TV
six quadrants wouldn't be
quadrants, but six equal.
- Six four
(everyone laughing)
- Each was a live shot of
each one of our houses,
like a helicopter shot,
they've cast of friends houses
and I was like, Okay, what, what is this?
What's going on here?
And I'm watching it It was
like a not there was no
information and no news
really just showing the houses
and remember looking close at my house
and thinking (beep) I need a new roof.
(everyone laughing)
So the helicopter flies
away I get the ladder out
(mumbles)
- All right well man
with the plan is back.
So how is this show?
How do you love the
chemistry of this cast?
- This show is fun you know,
I'd finished doing episodes for Showtime
which was really fun.
And then, like I'd never played
a guy that was in a relationship or dad
and you know now I have a daughter
and I figure I'm old now It
must be its time to play dad
- [Kelly] You can play a dad
(laughing)
So just, you know, sort
of high concept show.
It's just about this family.
- Yeah.
- And when you-
- That's what's so relatable about it?
- There's so many things that happen
just in a regular family's life
that it's just been really really fun
and Stacy Keach plays my dad he's awesome.
Kevin Neon plays my brother
he's really hard to work
with because he's so funny.
(laughing)
I just end up laughing all the time.
Eliza Snyder plays my wife, and
we have a really great calf.
So we're at the season four now
and then I think it's
our best best season.
- I love that it's so relatable though
(crowd applauding)
'cause even the scene,
even the scene we just saw
I have totally heard
our 18 year old daughter
and my husband just like
completely arguing about her shorts
and how they were basically
a bathing suit bottom.
Yeah so it's like that
whole slow striptease thing.
(laughing) so hilarious
- Yeah, my daughter 16 now
wears the same kind of thing
now where is the rest of your shirt?
- Why are you we have money
you can afford a whole shirt.
(everyone laughing)
And then you start to
think about what you did
when you were younger and then
you just get frightened but-
- I didn't wear shirts like that ones.
(everyone laughing)
- I didn't either.
(laughing)
I know. I'm so nervous for our girls.